we're going to begin with this a
stunning phone call where president
trump has heard
pressuring officials to overturn the
election that he lost
cbs news has obtained audio of the
president asking georgia's republican
secretary of state
mr raffensberger to quote find thousands
of votes
that he would need to win of course it's
only the latest gambit in a months-long
effort to keep power
against the will of the american people
ben tracy is at the white house for us
ben good morning to you
some democrats but also some legal
experts say this could actually be
criminal behavior
what exactly did the president say on
that call well good morning in this
remarkable phone call the president does
vaguely threaten the state election
officials implying that they could be
prosecuted for not doing what he wants
and president trump says he wants
georgia to address his claims
ahead of the runoff elections there
tomorrow
there's nothing wrong with saying that
you know
that you've recalculated well mr
president the challenge that you have
is the data you have is wrong in a
stunning phone call this weekend first
obtained by the washington post
president trump pressures georgia's
republican secretary of state
brad raffensperger to find enough votes
to overturn
president-elect joe biden's win biden
has received 16
handing the state's 16 electoral votes
to him instead
so look all i want to do is this i just
want to find
11 thousand seven hundred and eighty
votes so tell me brad what are we gonna
do
we won the election and it's not fair to
take it away from us like this
and it's gonna be very costly in many
ways
and i think you have to say that you're
going to re-examine it
we have to stand by our numbers we
believe our numbers are right
georgia has now counted their ballots
three times declaring mr biden the
winner each time
the trump campaign has failed repeatedly
to prove any of their allegations in
court
and there is no credible evidence of
fraud on the phone call the president
continued to make allegations that have
been debunked
mr president the problem you have with
social media they can
people can say you know no this isn't
social media this is trump media
president trump baselessly accused
raffensberger of a cover-up
and threatened that he and his general
counsel may be in jeopardy
you know what they did and you're not
reporting it that's a you know that's a
criminal that's a criminal offense and
and you know you can't let that happen
that's
that's a big risk to you and to ryan
your lawyer that's a big risk some
republicans are concerned the
president's claims of fraud in georgia
will undermine
faith in tuesday's runoff elections
potentially costing his own party
control of the u.s senate
vice president-elect's kamala harris
campaigned for democrats in the state
sunday and sharply criticized president
trump it was a
bald ball-faced
bold abuse of power by the president of
the united states
now with concerns that president trump
may try to remain in office after
january 20th all 10 former living
secretaries of defense
including the two that served in the
trump administration wrote an op-ed
saying efforts to involve the u.s armed
forces in resolving election disputes
would take us into dangerous unlawful
and unconstitutional territory
today president trump vice president
mike pence and president-elect joe biden
will all campaign in georgia anthony
ben thank you